Starting with my first few tab presses,
the browser highlights the navigation
items for flights,
hotels and rental cars.
If I keep pressing tab it
takes me to the radio group
where I can choose between round trip,
one way and multi city.
Here, I can use the arrow keys
to select a round trip ticket.
We can keep tabbing and
filling in our personal information.
When we arrive at the destination,
we can use our arrow keys or
start typing to auto complete the field.
Similarly, in the date field we can use
our arrow keys or just type out a date.
Selecting window seat also relies
either on the arrow keys or
typing W to jump to
the window seat option.
And we can disable promotional offers
check box by pressing the spacebar.
The last thing to do is focus
the search button and press Enter.
There's something quite nice to
being able to fill out a form
using just your keyboard and
not having to switch over to the mouse.
Because all of the elements
used in the form are native
HTML tags with implicit focus the form
itself just works with the keyboard.
And we don't need to write any
code to add focus behavior.